foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is scp-2747
object class ketter previously Euclid
and Threat Level black previously green
special containment procedures
Foundation Watchdog algorithms are to
monitor online and print media for
mention of
scp-2747 positive key phrases all match
start to be tagged and forwarded to the
Department of analytics which will
provide further confirmation of
scp-2747 manifestation in case of
positive identification all affected
media are to be suitably corrected by a
standard foundation media alteration
protocols 912a Twilight Zone 943 a
poisoned well
observational procedure Lucid chalice
controlled observation of
scp-2747 will take place using local
Computing resources to procedurally
generate narratives at varying levels of
complexity and nestedness
simultaneously descriptions of the
narratives are to be generated using
Foundation media parsing analytic
meta-analytics software at varying
degrees of abstraction the results can
then be examined for signs of
scp-2747 by periodically scanning for
data irregularities any generated
narrative containing such irregularities
can then be flagged as an instance of
scp-2747 with its seed conditions
subsequently tagged as
scp-2747 conducive given a large enough
sample size the boundary conditions of
scp-2747 can then be identified and
mapped with a sufficient degree of
clarity
furthermore a watch list of 7 000
artists is to be maintained and observed
at all times for localized signs of
scp-2747 manifestation in their
respective Works using the
aforementioned analytic meta-analytics
software in order to increase the
observable resolution and range of
deeply nested meta-fictional
manifestations this watch list should
consist mainly of individuals groups and
organizations whose Works tend toward
containing meta-fictional content such
as mizona beams and stories within
Stories the sponsoring and or covert
influencing of such content creators can
be sanctioned to that end
the results of lucid chalice will be
documented within the current
documentation as appendix B
description
scp-2747 is a phenomenon appearing in
print and online media whereby platforms
dedicated to the discussion of works of
fiction begin to mention a non-existent
instance of fictional media despite said
non-existence articles posts comments
and other related meta content created
with regard to the non-existent work of
fiction will be found treating it as
real the non-existent work of fiction
can be mentioned by various individuals
in varying capacities ranging from brief
mentions and Forum posts to being the
subject of entire academic essays
descriptions screenshots photographs of
physical copies and brief segments of
text from said work of fiction can often
be discovered in
scp-2747 affected media descriptions of
it are entirely consistent with each
other and it is proven possible to
reconstruct whole segments of fictitious
media via descriptions of it taken from
scp-2747 generated medic content a list
of fictitious media generated by
scp-2747 has been appended below see
appendix a
where possible the affected material can
be traced to existing individuals
however when questioned under duress
said individuals invariably deny having
written the affected material and deny
all existence of the fictitious media
mentioned Within
scp-2747 has never been documented in
real time all observed instances thus
far have been recorded post-hoc no
instances have been documented prior to
January 2008. the reason for this was
previously unknown but it is now known
that it conforms to paid a physical
observations documented in full in
appendix B
it is the current hypothesis of the
Department of analytics than
scp-2747 represents evidence of a
naturally occurring and a fabula or
anti-narrative a cluster of independent
signs iconography and narims
that when included to a sufficient
extent within a fictional construct
leads to Mutual Annihilation first-hand
reconstruction of the anaphabulous
properties is impossible given its
anomalous nature but second hand and
third-hand descriptions have been
generated from observational procedure
Lucid chalice and appended Below see
appendix B it can affect through layers
of metafictional narrative I.E a
meta-narrative containing the anifabula
will cease to exist within the narrative
followed by The Narrative itself
disappearing from our reality
interpretation of metaphysical reality
layers of metafictional narrative has
yet to be verified by Foundation
observations at large but appear
concurrent with observations obtained
from trans fictional anomalies such as
scp-1304
scp-2614 and 001 the key identifier of
the anaphabula is that it invariably
represents an in-universe antagonist or
anathema in all manifestations of
scp-2747 likely due to inherent
narrowing components indicating its
alien yet centralizing nature
update the above mentioned hypothesis
has been confirmed as a working model of
scp-2747 please refer to appendix B
AIT the following procedures are to be
enacted following the successful
conclusion of observational procedure
Lucent chalice see appendix B
at no time are the properties of the
anifabula is outlined in appendix B to
arise in real life whether as a result
of deliberate or natural action any
object person or event bearing more than
significance level Alpha to the
semblance threshold is to be altered via
whatever means possible access to
information regarding
scp-2747 especially the information
contained within appendix B is to be
strictly limited to clearance levels for
2747 and three analytics due to the
pathophysical implications and inherent
uncontainability of
scp-2747 is detailed in appendix B it is
to be classified as ketter with
immediate effect
appendix a partial list of
manifestations of scp-2747
additional material
non-existent work referenced Punta de la
espira medium short story
extent of manifestation 17 articles
created and edited on wikipedia.org
summary of work Punta de la espera in
English tip of the Spire or spiral is
apparently a 1951 short story by Gabriel
Garcia Marquez it describes an unnamed
protagonist as he sails down a river
towards a desolate black-horned mountain
in order to deliver a gift to an
unspecified recipient the journey is
rough and treacherous and he dies of
exhaustion at the end of the story
appearing to be no closer to his goal
than when he first began the mountain is
described in detail throughout the story
with recurring metaphors alternatingly
alluding to it as either an abode of the
gods or a demonic presence
non-existent work referenced taitoru
Japanese
the film's title describes itself it is
the Japanese phonetic pronunciation for
the English word title title medium
animated film
extent of manifestation one article
created on tvtropes.org with 55 edits
made to various Trope Pages ranging from
despair Event Horizon to foreshadowing
and what do you mean it wasn't made on
drugs
summary of work tituru appears to be an
animated film directed by Satoshi Khan
shortly before his death it is described
as a psychological Thriller chronicling
a struggling manga Artist as she
attempts to complete and publish her
first work under a tight deadline stress
takes its toll and boundaries blur she
begins to hallucinate and the movie ends
Ambiguously as to whether she achieved
her goal or succumbed to her weaknesses
typical of Khan's style the animation is
described as meticulous kaleidoscopic
and occasionally deeply disturbing one
scene features the protagonist
physically grappling with the shadows in
her apartment described under the Trope
entry for your mind makes it real as the
manifestation of her creative block
which eventually engulf and consume her
non-existent work referenced no sister
of mine
medium video game
extent of manifestation 77 threads on
somethingawful.com each carrying between
3 and 103 comments most users were
established members of the something
awful community
summary of work no sister of mine is
supposedly a turn-based role-playing
video game of the fantasy horror genre
published by Pokemon
existed as a major game development
Studio operating out of Seoul between
2002 and 2005. no record of no sister of
mine has ever been found for the
Nintendo GameCube in 2005 according to
reviewers the player controls a party of
six unnamed characters as they explore a
ruined Kingdom with the intention to
find a lost companion referred to as
sister it was widely panned by the
reviewers with much criticism being
leveled at the glitch filmed battle
system incoherent dialogue seemingly
incomplete Graphics repetitive
soundtrack described as nauseating and
headache inducing as well as being
impossible to complete the game's
non-playable characters continuously
mention a Carl Black thornbound Tome
that when read from would enable one to
either obtain great power or unleash a
dreadful curse what most reviewers
assumed to be the final questline
required the player to backtrack through
the game's previous areas and recover
fragments of the tone using their
Newfound abilities however they
reviewers unanimously claim that no
fragments can be found One reviewer goes
as far as to claim that the items
themselves were never found inside the
game's coding in the first place
non-existent work referenced the
escoliopendra wiki
medium collaborative fiction
extensive manifestation 49 different
pieces of fan fiction ranging from 343
to 2401 words in length posted on
fanfiction.net each bearing between one
and six comments
summary of work the scoliopendra wiki is
deduced to be an online collaborative
fictional Universe belonging to the
horror speculative fiction and weird
fiction genres it appears to have been
hosted on some form of Wiki site though
the address itself is never mentioned
the exact nature of scoliopendra's plot
is hard to discern as the various pieces
of fan fiction sport vastly differing
storylines and range from character
interpretations further Complicated by
the involvement of other fictional
universes and settings what is known is
that it involves a cast of seven
characters wandering between a series of
Realms amassing and collecting items
possessing Supernatural or abnormal
properties one item features heavily
throughout the compiled Works a
seven-sided obsidian emblem set to
possess the power to destroy any object
person or abstract concept with a single
touch it appears to be of great interest
to The protagonists Who repeatedly make
attempts to acquire it however it also
appears to be currently in the
possession of a Sinister unnamed
antagonist who was alluded to repeatedly
in several Works yet is never seen
non-existent work referenced IO
medium musical album
extent of manifestation review columns
in a total of 14 reputable Publications
including the new Bombay times Pitchfork
and La flip side
summary of work IO is described as the
ninth studio album by the now defunct
English rock band Radiohead it contains
six tracks measuring a total of 34
minutes and 18 seconds the majority of
tracks appear to consist mostly of
digitally manipulated samples from
radiohead's previous albums lay it over
with sparse acoustic instrumentation and
vocals reception of the album appears to
be highly positive with the exception of
pitchfork's Jessica Green who gave an
average review of 7.0
Killer Bean felt that the album suffered
from Hasty and uncoordinated
post-production likely not undertaken by
Radiohead themselves audio Cuts between
the fifth and sixth track were described
to be unnecessarily jarring even the
seamless flow between every other track
in the album it is mentioned that the
album uses a characteristic grating
binaural Reverb layered over lead singer
Tom York's solo vocal trunk as a musical
Motif embodying what the new Bombay
times gulshan Annie rude believes to be
its Central themes of spirals of
isolation and inspiration of feedback
loops that resonate into the level of
the deeply personal the trembling core
of creative psyche anirud also mentions
lyrics referencing suicide and self-harm
though presented through a series of
oblique metaphors IO never fears to toy
with the idea of self-hatred and
self-desecration yet the album as a
whole seems to fall short of its Mark
always orbiting yet never quite touching
upon the Dreadful Center
non-existent work referenced maveen or a
traitis on the metaphysics of inner
space travel and the kingdom of Erica
whose name is Darkness made light and
further theological expositions thereof
medium novel
extent of manifestation seven articles
published in a single week in various
academic journals of literary criticism
each by reputable Scholars
summary of work maveen is described as
the contents of a manuscript and
accompanying charcoal illustrations
found in the house of a rhythabile
Abrams in 2014. Abrams appeared to have
been a reclusive writer and artist
working as a maintenance technician in
bloemfontein South Africa and clinically
diagnosed with schizophrenia a number of
individuals partially match this
Queen exists Movin is a nested frame
narrative written in Afrikaans
purporting to be a novel by the 17th
century Dutch Mystic it describes the
Journey of the Mystic whose name is only
given as mass learning of the structure
of the Earth's interior as revealed to
him in a vision at the beginning of the
novel Mars dreams of a supernatural
being that is aware of its nature as a
dream entity and is highly indebted to
mass for bringing it into existence in
exchange it promises to divulge to mask
the secrets of Earth Mars being
corporeal is unable to pass through the
ground and so the being decides to
Simply narrate the journey it speaks of
six Realms demarcated by thresholds
ranging from the realm of treasure and
minerals to an intangible plane of light
and sound Beyond these six Realms lies
another threshold this time one of cold
and silence which is described to be
Earth's core before it can be allowed
elaborated upon mass wakes and the dream
ends
non-existent work referenced x-locks
medium interactive novel
extent of manifestation in-depth posts
on seven different fiction review blogs
along with a mention in a Time magazine
article Ingrid
experimental narrative forms the title
is also mentioned in 175 Twitter posts
largely in the context of recommending
it as an interesting if underrated piece
of interactive fiction
summary of work x-locks appears to be a
work of interactive fiction of the
mystery genre written in a mixture of
English Catalan and Spanish it is
presented as a set of epistillary
narratives from the points of view of
six characters and a stream of
Consciousness narration of ambiguous
provenance readers navigate between
these seven-story threads discovering
hints of a murder or several murders
eventually the narratives converge at a
Roadside Diner during a thunderstorm and
the characters exchange their stories
from here the resultant narrative
structure cannot adequately be described
as simple framing devices or stories
within stories as the inner Tales
eventually begin to intertwine such that
later Tales shed new light on one's
recounted earlier or themselves linked
to segments of text earlier on in the
narrative after lengthy detours at
several points carried his attempt to
consult the testimony of an absent
individual referred to as the stranger
the identity of the murderers or victims
is never known nor does the story have a
conventional ending
appendix B
observations and conclusions from Lucid
chalice
additional material
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
welcome to another episode of extra
credit today we're going to be looking
at
scp-2747 written by minmin and explained
by Reddit user chaltac also with thanks
to taffeta so without further Ado let's
get to it
special containment procedures one thing
to call out is that the first image
contains a fractal a mathematically
defined image which has the same
characteristics as the whole meaning
that if you zoom in on a fractal you'll
see an image that looks identical to the
original this is clever for reasons
we're about to go into it matches a lot
of themes in this article
47 positive key phrases all match start
to be tagged and forwarded to the
Department of analytics which will
provide further confirmation of
scp-2747 manifestation in case of
positive identification all affected
media are to be suitably corrected by a
standard foundation media alteration
protocols 912a Twilight Zone 943 a
poisoned well
this tells us that the anomaly is
connected to certain key phrases that
can be found in media either online or
printed it's not just a phrase or word
though it's something that is made from
these phrases it's not a Cognito hazard
what about observational procedure Lucid
chalice
to procedurally generate narratives at
varying levels of complexity and
nestedness oh hang on a second let's
unpack that controlled observation of
SCP
nothing weird there
to really generate narratives procedural
generation is a method of creating data
algorithmically as opposed to manually
but what does that mean let's use a
video game example but let's say you're
in charge of Designing the art of a city
that will be full of brick walls you
could as an artist draw each individual
brick in every wall but that becomes
impractical very quickly no one wants to
do that when there are miles of walls to
consider instead you can create rules or
an algorithm that tell the software how
to draw a brick wall you can insert
rules such as create a pattern of red
rectangles separated by White Lines this
would look completely different in real
world usage you may want to add other
rules that make the wall look more
realistic such as have this much
graininess on the brick surface put in
this many discolored spots per square
meter this creates an algorithm which
tells the computer how to draw a wall
creating an algorithm is more time
consuming than drawing a single brick
but the computer can follow these rules
for as long as it has storage space and
totally autonomously procedural
generation is great for things that need
to run automatically or at higher speed
than a human could manage this means
that for whatever reason the foundation
needs to generate narratives or stories
automatically and at a faster rate than
humans can manage
simultaneously descriptions of the
narratives are to be generated using
Foundation media parsing analytic
meta-analytics software at varying
degrees of abstraction this means that
the generated stories are going to be
interpreted by software to create
summaries and descriptions at varying
levels of abstraction means the
descriptions have a range of detail for
example anything from a thesis level
analysis down to farm boy destroys
Planet Smasher with Space Magic
the results can then be examined for
signs of
scp-2747 by periodically scanning for
data irregularities
these descriptions are then scanned also
by computer for any irregularities
characteristic of whatever
scp-2747 is all of this should tell us a
few things so far first that the author
has really put some thought into exactly
how you would generate stories on mass
and make that data useful at a human
level second the foundation needs to
create and scan mind-numbing amounts of
narratives at a frantic rate whatever
2747 is it's very dangerous to Warrant
such intense generation and scanning any
generated narrative containing such
irregularities can then be flagged as an
instance of
scp-2747 with its seed conditions
subsequently tagged as
scp-2747 conducive given a large enough
sample size the boundary conditions of
scp-2747 can then be identified and
mapped with a sufficient degree of
clarity
ah this is research the foundation does
this to identify instances of
scp-2747 and know what tropes are parts
of the story or seed conditions lead to
2747 they can finally use all this data
to know exactly what causes or leads to
2747. we are seeing an anomaly in the
initial stages of understanding and
Discovery we're still finding out more
about the anomaly and actively
researching it as we go along this will
likely lead to further changes in the
containment procedures as we learn more
furthermore a watch list of 7 000
artists is to be maintained and observed
at all times for localized signs of
scp-2747 manifestation in their
respective Works using the
aforementioned analytic meta-analytics
software since 2747 is capable of being
made in any narrative with the right set
of Concepts and themes the foundation
also needs to be looking at artists
producing works to see if what they're
creating contains 2747 in order to
increase the observable resolution and
range of deeply nested metafictional
manifestations this watch list should
consist mainly of individuals groups and
organizations whose Works tend toward
containing meta-fictional content such
as mizona beams and stories within
Stories the sponsoring and or covert
influencing of such content creators can
be sanctioned to that end
nesting here refers to containing
something inside itself or something
similar for example reading a story that
itself contains a story a non-literary
example would be a Russian doll meta
fictional is a fictional story about a
fictional story house of leaves for
example contains both of these the
resolution and range part suggests
searching as if by telescope a mise on a
beam in literature or art refers to a
recursive piece of art like a painting
containing a smaller copy of itself
putting all this together this means the
foundation wants to be able to create
and study narratives that contain many
layers of fiction the results of
rotation has appendix B
to recap where we're at the foundation
is both monitoring art being produced
naturally and mass producing enormous
amounts of art to identify 2747 which is
something that emerges from certain
themes and tropes found in art it's not
yet fully understood so in-depth
research is still going on it's also
ketter class so we know it's highly
dangerous and resists containment
description
scp-2747 is a phenomenon appearing in
print and online media whereby platforms
dedicated to the discussion of works of
fiction begin to mention a non -estant
instance of fictional media despite said
non-existence articles posts comments
and other related meta content created
with regard to the non-existent work of
fiction will be found treating it as
real the non-existent work of fiction
can be mentioned by various individuals
in varying capacities ranging from brief
mentions and Forum posts to being the
subject of entire academic essays this
is telling us that 2747 is a phenomenon
where people will start to talk about
and react to a piece of fiction that
does not exist reviews are written fan
sites are created fan art is drawn
shipping commences effectively it's the
appearance of every bit of influence a
piece of fiction would have but without
that specific piece of fiction actually
existing again I'm getting strong House
of leaves Vibes descriptions screenshots
photo graphs of physical
cons of text from said work of fiction
can often be discovered in
scp-2747 affected media descriptions of
it are entirely consistent with each
other and it has proven possible to
reconstruct whole segments of fictitious
media via descriptions of it taken from
scp-20 747 generated meta content a list
of fictitious media generated by
scp-2747 has been appended below see
appendix a the anomalous portion of this
is that this echo of the work of fiction
this fandom reaction cultural imprint of
the story is entirely self-consistent
even to the point of being able to
reconstruct segments of it from
references to it where finding these
Echoes of the fictional story but we're
not finding the story itself where
possible the affected material can be
traced to existing individuals however
when questioned under duress said
individuals invariably deny having
written the affected material and deny
all existence of the fictitious media
mentioned within except of course if you
ask the authors of these Works they have
no idea what you're referring to SCP
2747 has never been documented in real
time all observed instances thus far
have been recorded post-hoc no instances
have been documented prior to January
2008. the reason for this was previously
unknown but it is now known that it
conforms to paid physical observations
documented in full in appendix B this
starts by saying that we've never seen
it actually happen we've only seen the
after effects and we have no idea why
but then this was altered due to new
information and that word paid a
physical shows up if you're not familiar
with this term here's a refresher meta
describes reality using symbols like a
metaphor Jane slept like a baby Peta
describes the meta like meta describes
reality it's one step up Jane slept like
a baby which had tired itself out
destroying the playroom like a tornado
it is the current hypothesis of the
Department of analytics that
scp-2747 represents evidence of a
naturally occurring and a fabula or
anti-narrative a cluster of independent
signs iconography and narims that when
included to a sufficient extent within a
fictional construct leads to Mutual
annihilation
narim here is a fundamental unit of
narrative akin to a Trope or concept the
farm boy with Noble Heritage the magic
sword darkness Etc
this means if you have the right set of
signs icons and Concepts occurring in a
fictional Universe the combination
annihilates the fictional Universe from
The Real World real as far as the
foundation is concerned anyway firsthand
reconstruction of the anaphabulous
properties is impossible given its
anomalous nature but second hand and
third hand descriptions have been
generated from observational procedure
Lucid chalice and dependent below see
appendix B
because the Anna fabula annihilates the
fictional Universe it appears in there's
no way to study it directly which is why
the foundation is piecing things
together with their mass-produced
fiction it can affect through layers of
metafictional narrative I.E a
meta-narrative containing the anifabula
will cease to exist within the narrative
followed by The Narrative itself
disappearing from our reality and this
is where things start to get interesting
say you have a movie which contains a
book in the book inside the movie which
the characters describe the plot of the
anaphabulous forms the first thing
that'll happen is that the movie will
continue to exist but without the book
characters will still reference the book
as they did before but the book itself
will be gone at some undefined point
after that the movie itself will vanish
from reality
there's also a footnote here
interpretation of metaphysical reality
layers of metafictional narrative has
yet to be verified by Foundation
observations at large but appear
concurrent with observations obtained
from trans fictional anomalies such as
scp-1304
scp-2614 and 001 redacted this means
that the foundation through looking at
anomalies that deal with multiple layers
of fiction has theorized that they
themselves are in a fictional universe
and that all of reality is fictional
universes contained within each other
I.E we write about the foundation which
writes about a book which contains a
movie Etc we also do learn one thing
about our Ana fabula
the key identifier of the Anna fabula is
that it invariably represents an
in-universe antagonist or anathema in
all manifestations of
scp-2747 likely due to inherent
narrowing components indicating its
alien yet centralizing nature
update the above mentioned hypothesis
has been confirmed as a working model of
scp-2747 please refer to appendix B this
Theory reality itself being multiple
layers of fiction works as a model to
predict
scp-2747 if nothing else
next are some instructions that say what
will change in the containment
procedures if the foundation is ever
able to fully deduce and describe the
anaphabula from Lucid chalice
the following procedures are to be
enacted following the successful
conclusion of observational procedure
Lucid chalice see appendix B
at no time are the properties of the
anaphabula is outlined in appendix B to
arise in real life whether as a result
of deliberate or natural action any
object person or event bearing more than
significance level Alpha to the
semblance threshold is to be altered via
whatever means possible access to
information regarding
scp-2747 especially the information
contained within appendix B is to be
strictly limited to clearance levels for
2747 and three analytics due to the
pathophysical implications and inherent
uncontainability of
scp-2747 is detailed in appendix B it is
to be classified as ketter with
immediate effect
the foundation with their theory that
they themselves are in a fictional
narrative do not want the anaphabula to
ever be assembled in their reality as
that would then lead to the annihilation
of their world because of this appendix
B which contains the results of lucid
chalice the foundation's full
understanding of the anifabulous nature
and how it works is restricted to need
to know personnel only appendix a is a
list of
scp-2747 manifestations situations where
this fictional narrative clearly existed
at one point but now has been wiped from
reality the descriptions of the
annihilated fictions do give us some
clue to the nature of the Ana fabula due
to common themes those themes include
Darkness Shadow black objects fiction
being annihilated and the inability to
complete or create a fictional work the
annihilated works cataloged here include
taituru a Japanese animated film IO a
musical album and the Scully pendro Wiki
a collaborative fiction Wiki
specializing in horror
and here's the core to the article the
juicy Center we've all been waiting for
appendix B the observations and
conclusions from Lucid chalice this is
what the foundation has learned about
the Anna fabula how it's formed the
characteristics of it everything
collected into a single place it's as
complete of a description of the
anaphabula that can be formed
really though we should have expected
that if you collect a full description
of a purely fictional entity what's the
difference between the description of
that entity and the entity itself
only the foundation could look an
apocalypse in the eye and feel annoyed
by it they have another one to add to
the list
so here we are the foundation discovered
a recursive fiction annihilating
phenomenon which has a lot to do with
dark shadowed structures a sentient
antagonistic entity and fiction being
annihilated there's that recursion again
it has destroyed who knows how many
fictional narratives destroyed the
narratives that contain those that it's
already destroyed and finally chewed its
way up to the foundation's lair Now by
studying the anaphabulous so heavily the
foundation has accelerated its own
destruction by giving it so many
opportunities to enter their universe
and by creating one in the layer just
beneath them did it have a start was
there some poor hapless scientist an
infinite number of layers down who
created this and it's been chewing its
way up the entire time or is it just
entropy manifesting in another manner is
it Turtles all the way down
Honestly though can you imagine how
terrible it would be to lose the
foundation imagine the entire SCP Wiki
just Vanishing and all there would be to
describe it would be posts like this
cataloging an annihilated universe
and then we'd follow suit
don't play with recursion kids you'll
never stop
all right thanks again to child Tech and
taffeta and also minmin for writing the
article itself and that about does it
today thank you for listening if indeed
indeed you still are and you're all
dismissed again
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Indy versus the world
big sip
tomothy
zargaron
the Morrigan
fire of time
Spencer arduin
rubbish bin 69
broken sketch
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Spencer J Tope
vinyl
zazapan
Lam k
Dr Briggs
signor
alatreon
your local Foundation agent derivative
Lost Boy
Lyndon B Johnson
oh crap guy
and James Saba
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you